it's cuba's most celebrated anniversary
the failed attack on the moncada
military barracks by fidel and raul
castro which marked the start of the
cuban revolution
69 years later raul castro now 91 still
appears to be going strong
but it's his successor miguel diaz canel
who must deal with escalating
disenchantment with the revolution
the imperial logic is betting on amnesia
of our history and social paralysis they
are betting the material needs provoked
by 63 years of their infamous blockade
will break the spirit of resistance of
our people
he was of course referring to the
world's longest economic embargo
imposed on cuba by the united states
cuba is undergoing its worst economic
crisis in 30 years power blackouts this
month in the middle of the stifling
summer have led to street protests
[Applause]
while tens of thousands of cubans are
fleeing
diaz canel continues to argue that the
u.s economic embargo is the root of all
of cuba's woes but on this occasion he
issued a novel challenge to the united
states
we conclude that they maintain their
blockade because without it our country
would be a model of a humane society too
subversive for the current world order
if i'm wrong then lift the blockade
immediately completely and without
restrictions and remove our so-called
pretext
in the meantime diaz canel promised that
in a few weeks he'll announce the
details of an economic reactivation plan
to counter acute shortages of food
supplies and energy
he ended the ceremony with the
traditional though increasingly
questioned cry of socialism and
fatherland or death
[Music]
lucian newman al jazeera